foreign
you're on the Ramsey Show how's it going
hey guys good thanks for taking my call
today
um so I'm fairly new I've been about
three weeks new to this whole Ramsay
show that stuff to work on and it came
at a perfect time because I have a
mountain of debt and uh just wondering
what the fastest way to pay it off would
be it's about a total of 850 000 and
that's including mortgages okay lay them
out for me with the Consumer Debt first
okay Consumer Debt first so I've got uh
4 000 on an LLC I've got a MasterCard
with twenty four thousand uh a car with
000 a truck with 77 000
um and then we've got my personal house
which has got a mortgage remaining of
550 000 and then a rental house with a
remaining mortgage of 170
000 plus a HELOC on my personal house
which is about 190 000. holy goodness
you've been collecting this stuff man
what is your income and not too proud
about it uh my household income is about
160 to 170 000. okay
what is the truck for
it's
it's vehicle that we bought with me and
my wife we have five children and we
wanted something to be able to pull a
trailer to take our family on vacation
do you have an RV
uh no we actually pulled my parents um
27-foot trailer to go camping up in
yokanagan okay
it's time to buy some tents I think for
now we vacation in our home because we
are in the backyard broke I think this
truck needs to go that's staring me down
in a bad way and because you can sell
this stuff I'd probably sell the truck
in the car just to help clean some of
this up to give you guys some breathing
room
but what you do here's what you do
ignore the mortgage parts for now let's
focus on this Consumer Debt and lay them
out smallest to largest that makes it
palatable right if you go how quickly
can you pay off this 4K and LLC debt
um a month we just wrote actually our
thing up last night on our plan and
we're hoping to have that paid off by
the end of August okay so end of August
we knock out the first debt what's the
next biggest debt the credit cards uh if
we sell the car
car is 21 the MasterCard is 24. okay
now my my personal plan because I can't
breathe right now is to just sell these
vehicles and just drive beaters for now
even if they're two ten thousand dollar
cars we're not going on vacation we're
broke so we can't afford that anyways
we're not Towing any trailers anytime
soon what if we cleaned up the car debt
that alleviates a hundred thousand of
this Consumer Debt
now you just have credit cards in front
of you for Consumer Debt then we're at
the mortgages you see how that just
speeded a sped up that process
yeah no absolutely our truck
unfortunately a month after we bought it
we actually got hit and it's been now
had to be fixed it had about twenty
thousand dollars in damage a month after
we bought it so I've thought about
selling that but from what I've heard
from I was talking with an insurance
adjuster they figure it's only worth the
price has dropped about 30 to 40 percent
based on that accident what we could get
for it so we'd still be left with like
20 to 25 000 remaining on that even
after you fix it up
well it's already been fixed we've had
it for a little over a year now but it's
our it's depreciated the value because
of the accident
yeah exactly yes well you said your
income was how much one 140 160.60 to
170 16170 is there a way to increase
that
uh I'm I'm already working overtime now
my wife's also starting to pick up some
overtime to help
um bring that up as well okay well
there's no easy shortcut way out of this
and there's no amount of debt you can
move around to make this go away the
only way to make go away is aggressively
paid off with the debt snowball smallest
to largest increase the income decrease
the expenses find as much margin as you
can to throw at that smallest debt and
just work your way at this thing and I'd
probably sell the rental what's the
rental absolutely
uh we're around three hundred thousand
so you could net about a hundred plus to
throw at the other debt
yeah and that would that we use actually
I know this is terrible thinking on my
part looking back now but we've used our
home equity line of credit to purchase
our rental house and it had a slew of
repairs to the extent of about seventy
thousand dollars more than what we were
expecting and that's where we have our
HELOC from
okay but you can still sell the rental
yes that's a game changer you have to do
that it gives you pretty big momentum to
get this thing started now there's still
a lot of work to do but that'll help and
even being underwater on that car on
that truck I'd probably sell a rental
and use that to cover the underwater
portion yep sell the car get two beater
cars that at least cleans up a whole lot
of this debt that leaves you with the
LLC the credit cards and the HELOC and
then save the mortgage till the very end
okay what's what is the house worth
um my personal residence yes
uh about a million dollars okay
now I don't think you need to sell the
house unless this mortgage payment is
killing you guys is it a big part of
your monthly take-home pay
it's right around that quarter per Mark
it's about uh 2500 a month okay and
you're bringing in 10k with
approximately 10. okay yeah so I didn't
think the mortgage was the problem and I
would just save that to the very end I'm
not a huge fan of just using that as the
first shortcut to just sell the house to
get out of this thing I want to see some
Behavior change otherwise you're going
to be right back in this mess a year
from now
and that means the sacrifices of paying
off the truck that we use for the family
vacations and the car and we've got to
stop looking for shortcuts and I feel
like you're ready for that
yeah is your spouse on board as well
um
at first it was tough like you know I've
been with link to your Garden's podcast
religiously for the last three weeks
um and she's not quite on board but
she's definitely more on board now that
we've kind of put it out on paper kind
of a plan on what I I was planning on
doing
um but I figured to call you guys I
think I think she'll be able to come on
board with it might be a little bit of a
struggle but if you just the
conversation show her these numbers on
paper show her the interest show her how
long it's going to take to crawl out of
this thing she's going to be willing to
sell some stuff yeah I agree I can't
read looking at this stuff man I'm
pulling for you to get out of this thing
call us back if we can help in any way
you imagine just looking at the budget
once all those things are paid off that
we just talked about by the one pert
sale of the house that's Game Changer
and that's that'll get somebody on board
show them real numbers